scp-5000 gunshots echo down the concrete
hallway of site-22
screams are the only thing that escape
each room a team of men in all black
combat gear and masks move from one
section of the complex to the next
pietro wilson hides in his office
listening to the cries for mercy of his
colleagues
he shakes uncontrollably with fear who
are they
he thinks why are they killing everyone
and how did they find us
moments earlier pietro wilson had been
in the canteen eating dinner with other
staff members
a group of heavily armed men entered the
room they stood silently surveying the
area
one of the scientists stood up and asked
if they could assist them that's when
the carnage started
one of the masked men raised his rifle
and shot the scientist in the head chaos
broke out as the other mercenaries
raised their weapons and began
firing bullets flew everywhere and
piertro was lucky not to be struck or
trampled as he escaped out the back door
of the cafeteria
he ran to his office slammed the door
shut and hid under his desk
now he sits on the floor with his legs
pulled up to his chest
shaking uncontrollably after a couple of
minutes
he manages to take a deep breath and
slows his heart rate
he regains control of his body but is
still filled with fear
and adrenaline pietro crawls on his
belly to his office door
he reaches up and pulls down on the
handle there's a slight click as the
latch releases
he opens the door just to crack and
peers out into the hallway
the flickering emergency lights
illuminate the corridor for a few
seconds at a time
before plunging it back into darkness
there is no one in sight
but from around the corner flashes of
light from machine gun fire flickers
down the hall
the screams of the workers at site 22
are silenced
pietro takes a deep breath and pushes
the door open further
he crawls out of his office and starts
moving away from the violence
unfortunately to get away from the
mayhem he must go deeper into the bowels
of sight 22
the exit is the other way but he is too
scared to head
towards the armed men he stands up and
brushes the dirt from his blue
technician jumpsuit
the lights flicker off the hallway goes
dark he reaches out his hands and comes
into contact with the cool damp
wall he feels his way down the corridor
swimming
in darkness after a few moments the
lights flicker back on
pietro looks over his shoulder to make
sure he is still in the clear
standing at the end of the hall is a
soldier dressed in all black with a mask
covering his face
the soldier stands motionless pietro
turns to face the soldier
his eyes open wide his heart races he
can't breathe
the figure doesn't move then the lights
flicker out again
and pietro pushes off the wall and runs
blind in the darkness
he sprints as fast as he can when
suddenly there is a loud crack
and a bullet whizzes by his head he can
feel the wind as it barely misses his
cheek
he continues to run the lights flicker
back on he peers over his shoulder
now there is an entire group of armed
men pursuing him down the hallway
guns raised he turns the corner of the
hallway and proceeds down a set of
stairs further into site-22
at the bottom of the stairway there is a
short corridor with a door at the end of
it
there is nowhere else to go he pulls a
key card out of his pocket and fumbles
it
the card falls to the ground pietro
bends down to pick it up
and as he leans over a bullet whizzes
past where his head had just been
the projectile embeds itself into the
metal door he scoops his key card up off
the ground
and shoves it against the scanner the
door unlocks and he dashes into the room
he quickly turns and shuts the door it
locks automatically the last thing he
sees is the assassins running towards
the door
the lights flicker on in the room where
pietro stands the room has only one door
no windows and no vents it is completely
isolated
in the middle of the room is scp-5000
he knew there was an scp in this room
that was designated scp-5000
but he never knew what it actually was
here he is now
staring at it a strange-looking
mechanical harness hanging in the middle
of the room
suddenly loud banging at the door fills
the room the armed men are trying to
break in
it is only a matter of time before they
pry the door open with nowhere to go
pierce wilson knows that he is dead he
looks at scp-5000 and shakes his head
what do i have to lose he says out loud
only your life
a voice in his head responds he walks
over to scp-5000
and pulls it down from where it is
hanging it is heavy on the mechanical
suit are symbols he does not recognize
the only thing he knows about the suit
are rumors he's heard from others who
work at site-22
supposedly it first appeared in a flash
of light in the containment chamber of a
ketter level scp at site-62c
the designation of this ketter was
scp-579
the only other thing that pietro knows
is that everyone at site-62c was
slaughtered when containment was
breached
scp-5000 was found deactivated next to a
pile of bodies
he slips on the harness and as if it has
a life of its own
scp-5000 begins to adjust itself to the
exact dimensions of his body
the suit grows and snakes across his
skin wrapping every appendage in
armor then it begins to tighten pietro
wilson starts to scream as scp-5000
envelops him the suit rises up the back
of his neck and encases his entire head
silencing his screams the door to the
room blasts open from a controlled
explosion
as the dust and smoke settles the masked
men enter the room
their flashlights move from side to side
as they search for the elusive
technician who had just entered
there is no one in the room all that is
there is an empty rack in the middle of
the chamber
the men fan out there was no other exit
the room is just a solid square of
concrete
they're baffled where did he go one of
them shouts pietro wilson had blacked
out from the pain of the suit attaching
to his body
he comes too still standing in the
middle of the room
all around him are men in black combat
gear they are searching for him
he holds his breath and closes his eyes
but the gunshots never come
he opens one of his eyes and looks
around why haven't they killed mia
he thinks he slowly turns his head as
men walk by him
with their guns raised he hears someone
say where did he go
i'm right here he thinks am i dead
pietro looks down to see that his entire
body is contained with an scp-5000
he lifts his hand and waves it in front
of his face he is still clearly alive
but it seems as if the killers can't see
him he walks up to one of the
mercenaries and waves his hand in front
of a man's face
there is no reaction the suit made me
invisible
he thinks pietro looks at one of the men
to see if he can find out who they are
and why they have killed everyone at the
base on the sleeve of the man's jacket
are the words zeta 19 he's never heard
of zeta 19 before
but they must be part of an organization
that is trying to undermine the scp
foundation
the men continued to search the empty
room clearly confused as to where the
technician went
pietro weaves his way through the group
of men and back out the door he had
entered from
on his way through the wreckage that
used to be a door pietro wilson trips on
some debris
he reaches out to steady himself but he
has fallen he closes his eyes knowing
that as soon as he hits the ground
all the men hunting him will be alerted
by the sound of his fall
but the impact never comes when pietro
opens his eyes it is as if he is
hovering just above the ground
he looks down at his feet the toes of
the suit are firmly planted on the floor
like powerful magnets on iron scp-5000
has prevented his fall and is holding
him in place using the feet of the suit
only
he reaches out his hand and gently
places it on the ground he pushes
himself
up to a standing position he turns to
look back into the room
the men are still in there searching for
him pietro makes his way
back through site 22 he walks by his
office and proceeds towards the exit of
the facility
as he passes the labs and other rooms at
site-22
all he finds is carnage everyone has
been killed
an extra bullet has been placed in each
person's head to make sure
it seems that the only mission these men
were on was to kill
everyone and make sure they stayed dead
he continues towards the exit of site 22
that is guarded by two men
as he approaches the two heavily armed
men pietro makes sure to be as quiet as
possible
this is not a difficult task as the
scp-5000 has given him stealth
capabilities
he notices that even his footsteps
aren't giving off any sound
it is almost as if the suit is allowing
him to glide across the floor
he is almost to the exit then he will be
home free
he takes a deep breath turns sideways
and squeezes past the two men guarding
the doorway
just as he is about to leave this
nightmare behind one of the guards turns
unexpectedly
the man's shoulder runs directly into
piertro wilson throwing him off balance
he is knocked into the second guard both
of the men scream
what is that one of them shouts they
begin to raise their guns on the
invisible object that just bumped into
them
it's then that scp-5000 takes over
pietro's body
the suit raises his arm and grabs one of
the men by the throat
with a squeeze the man's larynx is
instantly crushed then the suit twists
slightly and snaps the man's neck
it turns to face the second man even the
black mask the man is wearing can't hide
the look of terror on his face
but piertro has no control over what
scp-5000 is doing
he has never killed before the suit
launches pietro's body into the second
man
pinning him against the wall it then
grabs the top of the mercenary's head
and slams it against the concrete
again and again and again until the
man's screams
are silenced the suit lets go of the man
and his lifeless body slides to the
ground
as pietro backs out when he regains
consciousness he's outside of site-22
standing on top of a hill
looking down at the facility below he
looks at his hands
then at the rest of his body he is still
contained with an scp-5000
there is a flash of light and a heads-up
display comes on he doesn't recognize
any of the symbols but as his eyes move
from one area of the screen to the next
the symbols become highlighted before
his eyes certain symbols begin to
translate into words he can read
one of the symbols now says journal
entry unsure of what else to do
pietro begins recounting what happened
to him at site-22
he makes his way through the desert
towards the nearest scp foundation safe
house
he knows once there he will be able to
reach out to his superiors for help and
further orders
maybe he can even find a way to get
scp-5000 to release him
as he trudges along petra wilson notices
that his brain is telling him he is
thirsty
but the vitals on the suit's heads-up
display say that he is in good health
in fact he is better than good his
vitals are all perfect
the suit seems to be giving him all the
nutrients his body needs
it has even fixed his busted knee that
was injured back in college playing
football
the joint itself has somehow been healed
pietro finally reaches the safe house
and opens the door
it is quiet and dusty it looks as if no
one has been there in years
he walks over to the communication
station and tries to contact the
foundation
but all he gets is static he gives up
and walks over to the tv
he pushes the on button the screen
hisses to life
what he sees causes his jaw to draw scps
had been let loose around the world
and were killing people by the millions
what was going on
pietro was startled awake from a
nightmare he was hyperventilating
but his body almost immediately
recovered and his breathing slowed
a heads-up display flashed on in front
of his eyes pietro wilson was still
contained with an scp-5000
the suit would not let him go he
instinctively went
to rub his eyes but the metal hands of
the suit just clanked against the helmet
that covered his head
he wanted out of this suit pietro stood
up and walked over to the television
he reached out to turn it on but paused
he thought
do i really want to see how bad things
have gotten since i fell asleep
but he had to know he was filled with
dread as the tv came
on and he saw the first images the world
looked as if it was ending
and it seemed like the scp foundation
was responsible
how could this be they were supposed to
protect humanity
not destroy it pietro needed to uncover
the truth behind what was happening
scp-5000 had a log entry function that
he could use to record everything he
uncovered
even if he didn't make it out of this
live maybe one day
someone would find the suit and be able
to access what he had learned
the date of his first journal entry was
february 1st 2020.
as pietro watched the carnage unfold on
tv he began to put together the pieces
of what he had witnessed himself
he knew a special op squad had executed
everyone at site-22 where he worked
he knew that the scps have been lot
loose he knew the world was ending
but why as pietro pondered this a
newscaster appeared
what you have just witnessed are reports
from around the world of monsters
ravaging cities and towns
this all started with a mysterious
message from an organization that calls
itself the scp
foundation their ruling body named the
o5 council released the following
statement
for those who are not currently aware of
our existence we represent the
organization
known as the scp foundation our previous
mission centered around the containment
and study of anomalous objects entities
and other assorted phenomena
this mission was the focus of our
organization for more than 100 years
due to circumstances outside of our
control this directive has now changed
our new mission will be the
extermination of the human race
there will be no further communication
he couldn't believe what he was seeing
the scp foundation had declared war on
the human race
how could this be what had led to the o5
council changing their entire mission
from protecting humanity
to ending it could it be possible that a
powerful scp had taken control
or influenced the council's decision
pietro turned on the radio
flipped through tv channels and scoured
the internet for information on what had
happened over the past 24 hours
the first image he saw was a human-like
creature with arms and legs twice as
long as they should have been with deep
black eyes
and a mouth curled up into a silent
screen showing teeth
as sharp as razor blades from the files
he could access
pietro learned that this was scp-096
a creature that was docile until someone
saw its face
at which point the scp would start to
shriek and cry before hunting down
whoever saw its face and slaughtering
them
he quickly changed the channel the file
said that even if scp-096 was seen on a
screen
it would find the viewer and tear them
limb from limb surely that couldn't be
true
there were potentially millions of
people who had just seen it on tv
what would happen to them what would
happen to him
on the next channel was footage of a
gigantic animal in the middle of the
ocean
this was scp-169 a leviathan from the
pre-cambrian era
the creature was around 5000 kilometers
long and slowly swam just below the
surface of the ocean
the feed suddenly changed to footage of
devastating tsunamis and destruction
caused by earthquakes
when scp-169 had been awoken from its
slumber by the foundation detonating
nukes on its back
it began trying to escape the danger the
movement of the massive creature caused
natural disasters
destroying coastal communities around
the world
on another channel pietro was watching
as the chancellor of germany gave a
speech
announcing that the country was
declaring war on the scp foundation
off camera the sound of a tinkling bell
could be heard a man dressed as a
victorian-era butler entered and picked
up a pen from the chancellor's desk
he approached the chancellor and raised
the pen in the air as the camera cut
away
but the sound of gunshots and yelling
could be heard before the feed went dead
the news reported that similar events
involving world leaders by the exact
same butler had been occurring since the
scp foundation changed its mission
pietro searched through the suit's files
to try and figure out what was happening
and found that scp-662 must have been
connected
next was a strange skin disease plaguing
new york and delhi designated
scp-610 that covered its hosts in rashes
and boils before seeking to take over
their bodies
finally some good news though as the
outbreak looked to be contained by the
combined efforts of the global occult
coalition and the church of the broken
god
and then some bad news as scp-682 had
also been released
a massive crocodilian monster its sole
mission was to destroy
all life it was fueled by hatred for
living things
making it the perfect tool of the o5
council's new stated mission
pietro had heard rumors of scps that
could instantly end the world but
clearly the foundation hadn't gone down
this route
yet did they want to keep the rest of
the planet intact
or maybe there were holdouts in the scp
foundation who were trying to stop the
o5 council from carrying out their
mission
all pietro knew was that right now there
were some real
nasty scps running around wrecking havoc
pietro suddenly heard an explosion in
the distance far away
but still close enough to make him
nervous maybe he was better off staying
in the safe house and waiting out the
apocalypse
the suit was keeping him healthy
nourished and undetectable to foes
any sane person would have remained
there in seclusion and safety
but pietro needed answers he felt it was
his responsibility to log and try to
make sense of everything the scp
foundation was doing
he brought up a map of scp sites in the
area on his display
the closest was site 19. it was time to
venture out into the end of the world
and find some answers but he was about
to be faced with
even more questions on the way to site
19
pietro came across something strange a
squad of foundation soldiers and a
clearing
they were standing at attention as their
commander paced back and forth
up and down the line the soldier's
uniforms had the insignia
mtf epsilon 6 embroidered on them the
commander stopped in front of the first
soldier in the line
clapped her hands and informed the
soldier she would be beginning the check
now
the commander pulled out a long knife
and plunged it into the soldier's
shoulder
strangely the soldier did not move make
a sound
or react in any way she moved on to the
next soldier and repeated the process
this continued on the line until she
reached the eighth soldier
this time when the commander stabbed the
shoulder of the soldier
he noticeably winced and cried out in
pain the commander shouted
got a live one pietro watched as the
soldiers raised their guns and fired at
the one who had cried out
he dropped to the ground the commander
moved on to the last soldier and put the
knife in his shoulder
there was no reaction all right we're
clear yelled the commander
let's move out pietro waited until the
squad was out of sight
and made his way to the corpse lying on
the ground he scavenged weapons and
basic medical supplies
then he buried the body and recorded
what he had seen in scp-5000's log
he had no idea why the soldier was
killed but why the others didn't feel
pain
maybe they weren't human at all maybe it
was a squad of scps that had a human
infiltrate their ranks none of this
makes sense
pietro thought before continuing on
upon reaching site 19 pietro found it in
disarray
and worse practically all the scps that
were held at the site had breach
containment
he was able to walk into the compound
unnoticed
and deep in the facility he found
scientists and researchers going about
their business
as if they had no idea what was
happening out in the world
they must have been following the orders
of the o5 council
pietro listened in on conversations
about how to create the maximum number
of human casualties
and which scp should be released next he
felt a deep hatred for the people in the
facility
how could they be so casual about wiping
out humanity
as he observed more of the workers at
site 19 he noticed something
strange everyone's eyes were cold and
dead like there was no humanity
left in them as if something had got to
these scientists
and removed the very souls from their
bodies pietro stealthily stole a senior
staff member's credentials and found an
empty office where he could access logs
from the facility to try to get a better
idea of the timeline of events that led
to the scp foundation's war
on humanity he logged into the mainframe
and brought up the entries from the end
of the previous year
he found that late in 2019 a project
called numa became of great interest to
the o5 council
from what pietro could tell the project
had something to do with the collective
human consciousness
also called the psychospace apparently
scp researchers had a breakthrough in
mapping out the psychospace
unfortunately many of the files had been
redacted and there was no way for pietro
to access the unredacted version
after pneuma had been brought to the
attention of the o5 council
a series of orders were sent out to all
senior staff and site directors
but frustratingly these orders had also
been redacted
all he could see was that after the
orders were sent out a wave of
resignations were submitted across the
foundation
suspiciously a wave of suicides had also
occurred at roughly the same time
what was in these orders the o5 council
then sent out a number of files to all
senior staff and site directors with
instructions to disseminate the
materials among those serving under them
after which both the resignations and
deaths immediately ceased
pietro searched everywhere for what was
in those files but like so much of the
scp database
this information had been redacted as
well what was clear was that the scp
foundation had begun gearing up for the
extermination of humanity the following
year
the entry log for february 1 2020 read
mobile task forces are dispatched to all
exclusionary sites to execute
all personnel immediately following the
conclusion of these missions the
foundation declares war on humanity
this was where pietro wilson's journey
had started he slammed his hands down on
the computer monitor in frustration
the suit absorbed all the impact and
crushed the monitor in half
pietro moved to a new non-smash computer
and logged in again
this time he brought up the most current
entries to see what the o5 council was
up to recently
to see if there were some answers in the
present the scp foundation had been busy
while he was making his way to site 19.
they had released scp-1048 in paris
which now led a horde of bears down the
champ elysee
in the distance pietro thought he could
almost make out a massive red
teddy bear walking between the buildings
the scp foundation was also launching
counter-attacks on any organization that
tried to oppose them
they used scp-1290 to hurl projectiles
at the global occult coalition's base
they were also using scp-1440 to
brainwash people and convince them that
they needed to riot
this caused widespread destruction as
people panicked and were trampled to
death
pietro thought it was sad that such a
kind looking old man could cause so much
destruction
he recorded as much as he could before
deciding that it was time to get out of
sight 19.
although scp-5000 still made him
undetectable
he couldn't shake the feeling that the
lifeless eyes of the staff
were beginning to look his way more and
more often
as pietro exited site 19 the sky glowed
orange with the fires of countless
burning buildings he needed to find more
answers
he needed to uncover the reason the scp
foundation was trying to wipe out
humanity
he had learned a lot from site 19 and
was sure that if he could just get to
the next site
he would finally be able to figure out
the foundation's motive
and maybe even how to stop them he took
a step forward
but his heads-up display suddenly went
completely dark
the suit constricted tighter around his
body slowing the blood flow to his brain
he couldn't move as his vision got
dimmer and dimmer
and dimmer until he blacked out
what happened pietro says out loud as he
looks at his vitals in the heads-up
display of scp-5000
he is still contained within the
exclusionary suit that makes him
undetectable to human senses
he checks the date and gasps in surprise
three months
i've been passed out for three months
he stands up and looks across the barren
landscape the screen
inside the suit indicates that he has
traversed half of the country since he
left site 19
three months ago pietro looked down at
one of his hands
he is holding a leather briefcase where
did that come from
he wonders pietro has no idea what is
inside the briefcase but he knows it
definitely
isn't round he tries to let go his
fingers won't open
he uses his other hand to try and pry
the briefcase away from himself
but his hand only clasps to it harder
then a wave of calm washes
over him something inside his head
speaks to him
but it's not a voice more like a feeling
it is a sense of purpose and pietro's
new mission in life is to deliver this
briefcase to scp-579
nothing else is as important pietro
wilson takes a deep breath and embraces
his new purpose in life
he still wants to uncover the reason
that the scp foundation is trying to
wipe out humanity
but this will have to wait until he
delivers the briefcase to scp-579
pietro doesn't know exactly where 579 is
located
but he can feel a pull in a certain
direction
so he begins to walk pietro brings up
the information stored in the scp-5000
suit from the foundations database
he finds that all information about what
scp-579 is has been expunged from the
record
the only useful information in the file
is that the ketter level scp is located
at site 62c
at least pietro has a destination to aim
for he travels for days without seeing a
living soul
but he does pass thousands of corpses he
tries to ignore them
but one stands out to him inside a house
as he searches for supplies
it's the body of a recently deceased boy
he couldn't have been more than eight
years old
he was so young pietro thinks
he bends over to scoop up the body and
bury it outside
as his hand touches the body the boy's
skin begins to move
it is as if hundreds of tiny creatures
are scurrying just
under the skin then from out of every
orifice comes hundreds of little pale
worms
each with the face of the boy they're
all cackling as they crawl out of the
boy's body and into a drain a few feet
away
pietro jumps back and runs this is the
last person i try to bury
he thinks pietro pushes forward the
hundreds of little laughing worms
haunting his thoughts
until he puts a significant distance
between himself and the little boy's
body
pietro continues to walk towards the
direction of site 62c
he passes more corpses but decides to
stay clear of them
although the suit makes it so pietro
doesn't need to rest he can only go
so fast he enters a small abandoned town
that looks like something out of an old
western movie
a tumbleweed blows across the dirt road
pietro sits on the wooden step of the
local saloon and takes a break
he looks down at the briefcase in his
hand he hasn't had the urge to open it
only to deliver it to scp-579
pietro puts the briefcase on his lap he
stares at it
and slides his hands along the leather
stops with his thumb on the latch
and pushes the locks snap open pietro
opens the briefcase
a bright light beams out and he passes
out
when pietro comes to again he is miles
closer to site 62c
there is a warm feeling enveloping his
body he looks down at the briefcase
which is now closed
wow this thing is like my own personal
skip button
pietro thinks he holds up the briefcase
unlatches the locks sees the bright
light and passes out again
he awakes once again miles away from his
last position
so it wasn't just a one-off effect
pietro continues walking across the
country
switching between using his own legs and
whatever magic is contained within the
briefcase
he is making faster progress now as he
walks through a dense deciduous forest
he comes across a pack of wolves eating
the remains of an scp agent
pietro is undetectable to the wolves
thanks to the scp-5000 suit
and he makes his way over to the pack
quietly grabbing a laptop
laying on the ground next to the agent's
body pietro takes the laptop and goes
away deeper into the forest
before stopping to boot up the computer
he has not forgotten about the horrors
the scp foundation has released
and he needs to know how the world has
been doing over the last few months
what he finds is not good
the scp foundation has triggered the
eruption of yellowstone
destroying scp-2000 which unknown to
pietro
contain the failsafe for rebuilding
human society in the event of a
world-ending scenario which
this was starting to look more and more
like
it was only a matter of time now before
the soot and ash thrown up by the
eruption blocks out the sun in much of
what is left of the united states
the foundation has also found a way to
get scp-2241 to do their dirty work at
refugee camps
the young brown-haired boy is most
likely being manipulated by the
foundation
under the pretense that they are only
doing what is best for their
child he has caused whole groups of
refugees to turn on each other
leading to a massacre the last entry
says that the young boy is being sent to
the global occult coalition hold out in
genzir
to help destroy some of the last threats
to the scp foundation
a series of other scps have been
dispatched by the foundation around the
world to continue the destruction of
humanity
they even managed to use temporal
anomalies to make it christmas time
everywhere around the world so scp-4666
the brutal yuletide creature that stalks
the homes of children
is free to cause chaos
pietro had seen enough he slams the
laptop shut
throws it against the trunk of a tree
and opens the briefcase again
he awakes standing feet away from a
group of global occult coalition
soldiers who are sitting around a
campfire
maybe they know why the scp foundation
is trying to end the world
he thinks he decides that it is too
risky to show himself to the soldiers
but take some solace in sitting around
the campfire with other living humans
the soldiers are sharing stories about
what is happening one catches the
attention of pietro wilson
it is strange but also may hold a clue
as to why the scp
foundation is trying to wipe out
humanity
one of the soldiers recounts an event
that he witnessed before leaving the
global occult coalition's headquarters
at genzir
they had just captured an scp soldier
trying to break into the base the
infiltrator's name was samuel
ross he had been strapped into an
interrogation chair and questioned
the interviewers were not getting
anywhere until ross was threatened with
torture
to which he responded do what you want
once you realize you're not supposed to
feel pain
there's nothing to be afraid of anymore
pietro sits up straight and starts to
listen more intently
he remembers stumbling across scp
soldiers on his way to site 19 that
exhibited the same
no pain mentality that this samuel ross
seems to have
after that odd statement by samuel ross
there was the sound of wind
it started slow at first then ramped up
until it was howling like a hurricane
that's when the screaming started the
screams became louder and climbed to a
higher pitch
then the room went dead silent the last
thing that samuel ross said was
look what you've done to yourselves i
told you you wouldn't like
it didn't you that's why you hear your
voice
but you wanted to know so badly i really
liked you guys
so i was trying to be nice we're so kind
to you you
know we fight in the light so you can
die
in the dark
disgusting pietro sits back on his
haunches and rocks back and forth
he has an ominous feeling that there is
a connection between the missing pain
of the scp soldiers and the reason why
the foundation declared war
on humanity the soldier who told the
story of samuel ross stands up
after that interview is when the
destruction of genzir started from the
inside
it is why the global occult coalition is
no more
god help us all the soldier finished
with his story
turns from the others and starts to walk
away as the soldier makes his way
towards the woods
pietro can just barely make out that
he's taken his pistol from its holster
before he disappears into the darkness
the world truly
has gone mad pietro opens the briefcase
and blacks out pietro sluggishly
continues his walk
he's moving down a rocky path in the
middle of the forest
and his will to keep going is slowly
being drained
the only reason he has not sat down and
given up is because of the driving urge
to get the briefcase to 579.
he wants so badly to concentrate and
discover the reason that the foundation
released the scps on humanity but the
need to reach 579 won't let him focus on
anything else he's noticed though that
every time he opens the briefcase to
skip ahead he makes
less and less progress the warm feeling
of the first few transports has been
replaced by a nauseated headache
every time he comes out of the trance
pietro exits the forest into an open
field
the wind blows across the high grass
looking like green waves
and standing scattered throughout the
field are statues
as pietro approaches he sees that they
are statues of mobile task force
foundation
soldiers he slowly walks closer to the
white marble statues
he reaches the first one and looks at
the face of the frozen soldier
his eyes have been scooped out all that
remains
are black empty sockets the arms of the
soldier have been carved into blades
like a praying mantis he walks past the
first statue and proceeds to the next
one
where he hears something move in the
grass behind him
he spins around to look at the statue he
could have sworn it was in a slightly
different position
no that's crazy pietro thinks
he continues to the next statue it is
another carving of an mtf
soldier no eyes blades for arms
this is really creepy pietro says aloud
he proceeds through the field he walks
up a slight hill and turns around to
look at the field of statues
what he sees is terrifying the statues
have all moved and are now in different
positions
it appears as if they were slashing
through the area looking for something
or someone pietro continues over the
hill and comes upon a group of refugees
they are picking through the field
looking for food to eat a fog begins to
move in
it is being swept across the meadow by
the wind pietro watches from a distance
as the fog envelops the small group
suddenly there is screaming and the
sound of blades going through flesh
the screams cease almost immediately
pietro runs down the hill to where the
refugees were
the fog lifts the group of people have
been cut to pieces
standing in the middle of the carnage is
one of the mtf soldier statues
blood dripping from its blade arms
pietro knows what to do
he runs after a few miles pietro slows
to catch his breath
those statues must have been created by
the foundation he thinks
it's as if they are frozen in place but
as soon as you take
your eyes off them they can move with
killer speed
even in the suit my eyesight can stop
them but they can't see
me they must know i'm there though since
they can't move
pietro wilson opens the briefcase once
again for what he didn't know would be
the last time
when he comes to this time he is near
site-62c
he can feel himself being pulled
stronger than ever in the direction of
his destination
he walks down a deserted road past the
husks of burnt vehicles and at the end
is the gate to site 62c there are no
guards or security of any kind
it looks like the site has been
abandoned for a long time and the gate
is wide open
beckoning pietro wilson into
where scp-579 waits
petro wilson enters the dark hallway he
somehow knows
leads down into the crypt of site-62c
the walls drip with what he hopes is
water from leaking pipes
but it has a metallic smell and is much
too red to actually be water he begins
to feel nauseous
it gets harder to breathe even the
scp-5000 suit can't keep him calm
he turns and runs back up the stairs out
of sight 62c
pietro begins to sob uncontrollably as
the memories of everything that has
happened over the past several months
suffocates his will to go on then
as if an invisible force that refuses to
let him go
takes control pietro feels as if a gun
has been shoved into the small of his
back
he is being sent back into site-62c
whether he wants to go or not he is
unsure if what is forcing him back into
the base is inside the briefcase
his own uncontrollable urge to know what
is going on or scp-579
itself but he cannot stop himself from
re-entering the doorway
and proceeding into site-62c he doesn't
know what
scp-579 looks like but pietro has a
sinister feeling
that it is watching him he reaches the
bottom of the stairway and proceeds down
a dark hallway
the power went out a long time ago and
the only light in the depths of site-62c
is the dim glow coming from the helmet
of the scp
5000 suit pietro notices long gashes
along the concrete walls
as if someone took a giant knife and
dragged it from one end of the hallway
to the other there is something at the
end of the corridor that pietro can't
make out
as he gets closer the lights on the
scp-5000 suit begin to flicker
the thing at the end of the hallway
seems to move slightly each time the
lights on the suit dim
the lights on the suit go out completely
and the entire hallway
is plunged into darkness only for a
second though and when the lights come
back on
a statue of an mtf soldier looms over
pietro
its eyes are empty sockets its lips are
turned up in a snarl
the arms have been filed into blades no
pietro screams he dodges around the
statue the moment it is out of his sight
he hears the sound of blades on concrete
as the statue of the soldier comes to
life and begins slashing its way down
the hallway
it cannot see pietro but it knows he is
there
it slashes all around trying to connect
with whoever is there with it
pietro runs to the end of the hallway
and reaches the door
he presses against the heavy metal door
to open straining against its weight
all while the blind statue is still
slashing coming closer
and closer the door is almost open but
then pietro feels a blade lacerate the
back of the suit
cutting deeply into the skin of his back
missing his spinal cord by millimeters
another blade enters through the back of
his shoulder piercing straight through
he somehow pulls himself through the
crack doorway and kicks the metal door
shut behind him
he can hear the banging and scraping of
blades outside the metal door
the creature has not given up and is
trying to break in
pietro turns around to see he is in an
observation chamber full of
instruments and screens blood runs down
his back from the wounds inflicted by
the statue
he walks slowly over to the window on
the desk in front of him
is a file labeled scp-579
he looks through the observation glass
and down into the chamber below
it is too dark to make anything out but
pietro can feel that scp-579 is down
there looking up at him
pietro looks to his left and sees a hole
in the floor he walks over
and looks down and leads right into the
containment chamber
of 579. let's get this over with
pietro says out loud he holds the
briefcase over the hole
and tries to open his hand his finger
won't budge
scp-579 wants him to hand deliver the
briefcase
pietro wilson takes a deep breath closes
his eyes
and steps into the opening of the hole
he falls
in the moments before he lands in
scp-579's containment chamber
something comes to him he realizes that
he isn't going to be a hero
he isn't going to figure out why the scp
foundation is trying to wipe out
humanity
and he isn't going to survive
he lands hard on the ground below it is
completely dark
except for a shadow that moves in the
corner of the containment chamber
pietro wilson creates one last log if
anyone ever reads this
please please figure out why
explain it to me someone
anyone i don't get it i just don't
get it scp-579 steps into the glow that
the scp-5000 suit is giving off
petra wilson looks up at it oh
so that's how it is he says before
scp-5000 creates its final log
live signs lost vital signs
lost scp-5000 appeared in a flash of
light
in the containment chamber of scp-579
located in site-62c the researchers
monitoring scp-579 had no idea where the
suit came from
or why it contained the body of pietro
wilson a foundation
employee who is assigned to site-06 and
is very much alive
wilson appears to have no knowledge of
scp-5000
or memories of the events logged in
scp-5000 databanks
although the suit is believed to have
been capable at one point of a number of
anomalous functions and abilities
the damage it has sustained has rendered
it inoperable
except for the storage of data files
which now have been archived and stored
on secure foundation servers but
is that really the case the fact is
the tale of pietro wilson and scp-5000
is one of the most complex and
mysterious events in the
scp universe you've got questions and
we've got answers
why pietro what was in the briefcase
what exactly happened at the end of the
story
and perhaps most importantly of all why
did the scp foundation abandon their
mission
and make destroying all of humanity
their new primary directive
whenever you're dealing with splintered
realities and mind-melting nightmares
there's bound to be a number of
interpretations and we're eager to
explain one of the more popular ones
right here
soon you'll know it all but to find out
we need to start
at the beginning our hero foundation
employee petra wilson was going about
his day at exclusionary site zero six
however normal operations were
interrupted when a mobile task force
turned foundation hit squad stormed in
and began executing employees left and
right as part of their wider plan to
wipe out humanity
pietro got lucky though and managed to
find scp-5000
making him undetectable to the invading
mtf squad
this brings us to our first question why
pietro
and how does killing foundation staff
help advance the o5 council's goal of
overthrowing humanity
the answer to both questions has
everything to do with the site that
pietro and his co-workers were at when
the attack went down
exclusionary site-06 exclusionary sites
are a very special kind of foundation
site that utilizes the same technology
as the scranton box
a container used to protect important
items from reality warpers but on a far
more
ambitious scale because of the use of
this technology
these exclusionary sites are essentially
resistant to ck-class restructuring
scenarios and temporal anomalies
those are where reality and or history
itself are changed by a powerful entity
this makes them a perfect location for
say staff wanting to stage a revolt when
their leaders have decided to wipe out
humanity
the foundation wished to eliminate the
personnel stationed at these protected
sites as a precautionary measure
before moving on to the main phase of
their plan
but this attack was just one part of the
foundation's wider scheme to purge their
ranks of dissenters before putting their
final mission into place
in order to make sure there were no
internal threats left who could pose a
threat to the new main directive
the foundation murdered all the staff at
exclusionary sites
hunted down and assassinated any
resigned employees
and killed off any humanoid or human
sympathetic scps
leaving no one who could stop them or at
least
they thought there was no one left while
all of this was happening
pietro suited up and exited the site so
why pietro because he got lucky and he
happened to stumble upon
scp-5000 he wasn't the chosen one
nor was he in any way exceptional beyond
his willingness to see
his quest for answers through to the
bitter end pietro really could have been
any of us
if we were in this situation when pietro
escaped
he found the world in disarray scps had
been released on a global scale
destroying infrastructure massacring
civilians and assassinating key
political figures
the foundation had even gone public for
the first time ever
with their new intentions destroy all
humans pietro decided to head to site 19
and get to the bottom of their madness
on his way there he saw a group of
mobile task force members
performing a bizarre stabbing ritual to
see who among them
could feel pain remember this it'd be
important later
like a lot of the small moments in the
story of scp-5000
these are puzzle pieces that can be fit
together to create the true
picture of what's happening out of the
chaos at site 19
among the dead-eyed foundation workers
plotting mass killings
pietro found a treasure trove of vital
information
there he learned about the existence of
project pneuma an o5 council approved
initiative to map out the human
psychosphere otherwise known as the
collective
unconscious he also found a redacted
unanimous vote from the o5 council
and ethics committee as well as a
redacted series of directives sent out
to senior staff and site directors
which caused a wave of suicides and
resignations
during his search pietro also discovered
a second series of directives sent out
to the remaining site directors and
senior staff
including the phrase harden your heart
these directives are known to some as
the cure while pietro didn't have the
context to put all this together yet
these are more vital clues to what
happened the pneuma project is what
incited the foundation's motivation to
destroy humanity
killing off humans is actually secondary
to eliminating something else that's
hiding within the human
psychosphere again that's the collective
unconsciousness of all
humans the o5 council and the ethics
committee were unanimous in their
approval of this project
which was like deciding to burn down a
house to kill the inhabitants inside
except in this scenario humanity is the
house
so who or what exactly is the inhabitant
you'll find that out
soon the next thing pietro knew he was
sitting halfway across the country
with no memory of the previous three
months he was also carrying a briefcase
with no knowledge of what was inside
except that it was not
round he also had a strange compulsion
to deliver the briefcase to scp-579
for reasons he didn't fully understand
but he hoped that doing so
would lead him to some answers pietro
may not have known what he was holding
but we do the clue here is not round
which is the only confirmed fact about
scp-055
also known as the anti-meme this is an
scp
with the primary anomalous property of
literally being
unknowable people who observe it forget
what they observed and have no memory of
even looking at zero five five in the
first place
this is why the briefcase was able to
act as pietro's personal skip button
pietro was physically covering the
distance he traveled but every time he
opened the briefcase and looked at
scp-055
he forgot that period of time making it
seem as though he simply skipped
forwards
the thing he was skipping towards
scp-579
is an equally mysterious and highly
dangerous scp
contained within site-62c nobody even
really knows what 579 is
only that it's an anomaly so dangerous
that the entirety of site 62c
was built to contain it so what's so
important about bringing these two
together
that and the vital importance of
pietro's final mission
will become clear very soon pietro
continued his journey with the briefcase
encountering more horrors and countless
deaths upon the way
he finally found some solace in coming
across a group of global occult
coalition soldiers
discussing the interrogation of a
captured member of foundation staff
named samuel ross two quotes from ross's
enigmatic speech are of particular
interest here
the first in response to the threat of
torture was
do what you want once you realize you're
not supposed to feel
pain there's nothing to be afraid of
anymore
the second after witnessing the death of
his captors was
look what you've done to yourselves i
told you you wouldn't like it didn't you
that's why you hear your voice but you
wanted to know
so badly i really liked you guys
so i was trying to be nice
we're so kind to you you know
we fight in the light so you can
die in the dark disgusting
do these quotes sound a little familiar
the first because
as pietro himself recalled the mtf
members getting stabbed earlier also
didn't seem to feel pain
the second because describing people as
disgusting
is an adjective favored by another
infamous scp
scp-682 this brings us back to the cure
the document disseminated by the o5
council
instructing people to harden their
hearts whatever the foundation
discovered in the human psychosphere
it's apparently the cause of all pain
and hence when the foundation discovered
it
they were able to train themselves out
of pain
and as for the scp-682 reference
this is a being that despises life and
it's believed by some that the reason
6a2 holds this belief
is that it's always known about whatever
the foundation recently discovered
through project numa
decrypted text logs in the foundation
files confirmed this in a document
exchange between 05-1 and tajani
the head of the foundation ethics
committee in their conversation
they confirmed the existence of the cure
which deprived the personnel of
everything from pain
to empathy being disseminated among
staff prior to the massacre
and of the foundation's sudden
ideological alignment with scp-682
and they found something else too
referred to simply as
it whatever it was it was the reason
foundation command decided to wipe out
humanity
but what is it what could possibly be so
bad it was worth killing
all of humanity perhaps most surprising
of all is that pietro ran
into the creature's physical
manifestation and he barely even
considered it
due to being occupied by avoiding the
attacks of the statue-like mantis arm
blinkers
pietro made an entry in his log though
describing the strange entity
describing it like a person stretched
out like the space around them was
stretched out and they were being
stretched along with it
their body went from the ground up to
the clouds and their jaws swung at right
angles
there were these gaps as well black gaps
in the space around its body
like wings foundation staff were
fighting it
shooting at this strange entity but
their weapons had no effect
this creature this it is a being that
inhabits the human psychosphere
meaning it exists within the minds of
all humans on some level
driving and manipulating them to
mysterious ends
what can it do what does it want it
seems that the only people who know
are the o5 council and the foundation
ethics committee who were privy to the
pneuma report
but whatever it was they saw they
believed it was worth killing off all of
humanity just to stop it
as indicated by the unanimous vote from
the ethics committee
omnicide was a more ethical choice
compared to the alternative
the influence of it was also likely what
gave pietro the strong subconscious
desire to unite the briefcase containing
scp-055
with scp-579 even at the cost of his own
life
this brings us to our final question why
was it so important to unite
scp-055 and scp-579
and what did this act serve to achieve
as pietro
wounded by the blinkers and lingering on
the edge of death
finally delivered the briefcase into
579's containment chamber
he acknowledged the fact that he was no
hero
but that's where pietro was wrong after
the destruction of scp-2000
pietro was in control of one of the only
remaining ways to save the world
the combination of the anomalous effects
of zero five five and 579
as laid out in rajit's proposal and the
article for scp-2998
is the foundation's ultimate trump card
for preventing an xk-class
end-of-the-world scenario if the two are
united during said scenario
the universe resets to a time before the
xk class scenario began
and prevents it from happening in this
case pietro united the two creating a
new reality where the pneuma project was
never launched
and it was never discovered thereby
adverting the apocalypse
the corpse of poor dead pietro and the
highly damaged
scp-5000 suit he wore were the only
evidence that this alternate reality
ever existed this means that the
collaboration between pietro wilson
and the suit he just happened to stumble
upon quite literally saved the universe
as we know it from a foundation that had
gone rogue
in this regard he's one of the greatest
heroes the universe has ever known even
if his actions weren't entirely
his own after all he got a helping hand
from the suit
and another from it who still lurks in
all our minds mercifully undiscovered
to this day what was its grand plan or
purpose that triggered all the madness
anyone who ever knew for sure resides in
a universe that no longer exists
and we can only hope that a history that
never happened
is somehow unable to repeat itself
in ours